hi guys welcome to an other video by
simply learn today I am going to help
you understand how to pass the AWS cloud
practitioner exam so let's get started
before we get started let us look at
today's agenda first we will go through
what is AWS cloud practitioner and its
eligibility criteria then we will go
through the exam objectives and its exam
content further we will not how to
prepare for the exam and look at a few
sample questions and finally we will
learn a few tricks relate to the exam
now what is AWS cloud practitioner a
double uses a variety of certifications
and a foundational level comes AWS cloud
practitioner going up we can achieve
professional and advanced level
certificates AWS gives a variety of
speciality certificates which is
something very unique it is a
foundational level certificate provided
by AWS it requires six months of AWS
cloud and industry knowledge becoming an
AWS certified cloud practitioner is
recommended it is an optional step
towards achieving an associate level of
speciality certification with the cloud
practitioner certificate you can get a
job as a cloud engineer or AWS
practitioner in many companies now let
us talk about the eligibility criteria
every exam has its own eligibility in
order to take the certification the
candidate must follow two important
criteria first he should have at least
six months of experience working with
AWS cloud concepts in Vedas rules like
Technical Sales and finance next it is
mandatory for him to have knowledge of
the AWS cloud platform and it's working
also he should know about the various IT
services now let's talk about the exam
overview the exam duration is 90 minutes
the candidate should get 65% of the
answers right in order to pass the exam
the question types of multiple choice
and multiple response questions the cost
of this exam is $100 every certificate
is valid for a few months or yours
aw slot practitioner is valid for two
years after two years this certificate
needs to be removed as in the exam needs
to be taken again let's get into the
exam objectives now the AWS cloud
practitioner
where it is the candidates strengths in
various domains first he should be able
to explain the cloud knowledge and his
platform he should know how to manage
the account he should know about the
billing and pricing details the
candidate should have knowledge of key
services available on the AWS cloud
platform the candidate should be able to
explain the various cloud values the
candidate should be able to explain
security concepts security model and
compliance concepts the candidate should
recognize the main sources of technical
assistance or documentation the
candidate must be able to explain the
key features of operating and deploying
in AWS cloud and finally he should be
able to explain the cloud architecture
and its basic principles in order to
excel in this exam we should know the
topics that occur in the exam so let's
take a look at the exam content the exam
has four major domains namely cloud
concepts security and compliance
technology and milling in pricing the
pie chart indicates the weight age of
each domain in the exam the cloud
concepts contain 28% of the total exam
content security in compliance contains
24% of the exam content technology is
the maximum weight age of 36 percent or
the total exam content and billing
apprising has the lowest weight age of
12 percent of the entire exam content
now let's dive deep into each of these
technologies
first comes cloud concepts in this you
need to have some basic knowledge of
cloud computing concepts questions asked
from this field are broad enough so to
perform well you must have high-level
flow concepts which include elasticity
scalability high availability and fault
tolerance next we have security and
compliance security is marked as an
important topic of whether you working
with infrastructure or not this
certification exam includes a variety of
questions related to security and
culpable management you may find some
important topics regarding this domain
in your exam as follows shade security
model cloud logs DDoS protection and I
am that is managing users password
policies and MFA the next domain is
technology technology is the most
important domain of the AWS cloud
practitioner exam if you want to adapt
in this section then you should have the
knowledge of Cole aw services some of
the aw sources that you must know are
ec2
we RDS s3s NS and ews lambda and finally
we have billing and pricing the AWS
certified cloud practitioner exam
constraints are the business
applications of ADA breeze billing and
pricing becomes important topics that we
should know you must have knowledge of
general account information
aw support how certain services are
built how to calculate the cost of
services and using what tools etc there
may be some questions which overlap with
other exam domains example AWS cost
calculator service may fall into billing
and pricing domain as well as technology
domain now that we know the domains
let's go ahead and see how to prepare
for the exam the first thing is we have
to start off with the AWS training
classes the following three EWS training
courses will help you pass the exam that
is AWS cloud practitioner essential need
obvious technical essentials and AWS
business essentials moving forward the
next step is to keep the AWS certified
cloth practitioner certification exam
guide this guide would give an idea
about the essential area that needs to
be concentrated on it provides an
overview of all the exam objectives with
preparation instructions the next step
is to get familiar with the subject
areas before taking any exam knowing the
subject areas is very important the exam
content has been explained before so
review the subject areas carefully plan
and prepare how to attempt the test
accordingly moving forward we have to go
through the AWS white papers these white
papers continues full information and
cover many important topics some of the
popular AWS white papers are overview of
AWS how AWS pricing works maximizing
value with AWS and many more self-study
is enough to pass the certification exam
the online training will help you
understand the subject areas a lot of
material can be found on the AWS website
also read the facts related to the AWS
cloud services applications and moreover
architecture the next important step is
to examine sample questions and take
free tests to ace the exam a practice
test is always necessary to see where
you stand and what subjects you need to
concentrate on AWS has many practice
tests and you can take them before the
exam the final step is to share you the
exam and get certified so once you're
prepared well enough then enroll for the
exam choose any testing center near you
at AWS training website
and register yourself going forward let
us look at few of the sample questions
that AWS website has so all these
questions are present under the AWS
website so you can go through them now
the first question is why is AWS more
economical than traditional data centers
for applications with varying computing
workloads so you can see the answer
choices on the screen the correct answer
is Amazon ec2 instances can be launched
on demand when needed the next question
is which AWS service would simplify
migration of a database to AWS
the choices are AWS Storage key to me
AWS database migration service Amazon
Elastic Compute cloud Amazon app stream
2.0 so the correct answer is e SS
database migration service the next
question is which kW is offering enables
customers to find buy and immediately
start using software solutions in the
AWS environment so you can see the
answer choices on the screen the correct
answer is AWS marketplace which AWS
networking service enables a company to
create a virtual network within AWS the
choices are AWS conflict AWS route 53
aw direct connect Amazon virtual private
cloud the correct answer is Amazon
virtual private cloud which of the
following is AWS responsibilities under
the aw shared responsibility model so
the options are configuring third-party
applications maintaining physical
Hardware securing application access and
data managing custom Amazon machine
images so the correct answer is
maintaining physical Hardware the sixth
question is which component of a double
is global infrastructure does Amazon
CloudFront used to ensure low latency
delivery the choices are AWS regions in
WH locations AWS availability zone
Amazon virtual private cloud the correct
answer is eight of these edge locations
so the seventh question is how would a
system administrator add an additional
layer of long and security to users AWS
management console the answer choices
are use AWS cloud directory audit AWS
Identity and Access Management rules and
evil multi-factor authentication and you
will AWS cloud trail so the correct
answer is to enable multi-factor
authentication the next question is
which service can I defy the user that
made the API call when an amaz
Elastic Compute cloud instance is
terminated so the options are Amazon
CloudWatch AWS cloud trail AWS x-ray AWS
Identity and Access Management the
correct answer is AWS cloud tree the
next question is which service would you
use to send alerts based on Amazon Cloud
watch alarms the options are Amazon
simple notification service AWS cloud
trail AWS trusted advisor Amazon route
53 the correct answer is Amazon simple
notification service and finally the
last question is vacant a customer find
information about prohibited actions on
AWS infrastructure so the correct answer
for this is aw is acceptable use policy
so you can see we get sample questions
like these you can go through the
website and see all the other
preparation and exam guides you need
finally the last topic in this video is
the tips while taking the exam since the
time is limited wasting time difficult
questions is unavoidable the next tip is
to keep a track of time and learn how to
manage time to answer all the questions
third one is unless the questions first
and then answer because sometimes they
may be traps and finally I spot the
guidelines some questions may have
multiple answers so read the questions
properly and choose the answers
carefully so this brings us to the end
of today's video I hope you guys enjoyed
the video thank you for watching and
stay tuned to more from simply alone
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here